I've shot two previous videos on this
important early work by Le shesto all
things are possible also translatable as
the apotheosis of
groundlessness and this is a work that
has a lot to say to to us from an
existential perspective not only in the
present but also reflecting on on the
present of shestov's own time which is
around the turn of the last century so
he's coming to us after after about a
century but everything that he's saying
is is really just as fresh and as vital
I think as it was back
then there have been two major world
wars um the fall of the the uh Soviet
Empire you know the the transformation
of the economy in a number of different
ways globalization but I think that what
he actually has to say here about the
the writer the The Thinker the
individual and and Society still holds
just as much Truth for for Our
Generations as it would for his own
generation and I'd like to begin by
going back to a passage that I brought
up in in one of the previous videos
where he's talking about philosophical
world
conceptions one of the things that we
want to think about is is there any
necessity in philosophy and that's a
very dangerous question for philosophy
and for philosophy ERS because as
opposed to the the other Sciences which
can have a sort of condition necessity
so long as you remain within this realm
you know there can be laws and we can
say there are norms that have to be
followed philosophy is about the whole
it's
about the big
questions the uh the first and and final
truths so if we can't attain
necessity then we're posed with these
sorts of questions that I'm going to
talk about in just a
moment and we start worrying about well
could I be wrong could I be off how do I
know that I can trust anything
so shof tells us every philosophic World
conception starts from some or other
solution of the general problem of human
existence so we all in some ways begin
on the same page but you know it you
might say the paper is crumpled in
different ways if we want to use that
metaphor some or other solution of the
general problem of human existence and
proceeds from this to direct the course
of human life in some particular
direction or another what this means is
something that other philosophers like
say n are getting at uh all philosophy
is ultimately practical in the sense
that it is oriented towards figuring out
what the hell am I supposed to do with
all of
this one of the responses could be to
contemplate it to think about it to try
to derive a science about it and that's
often or even to engage in epistemology
about it um theory of knowledge or
kentus era but that is
a choice that is a practical response
and there's a myriad other possibilities
he says we have neither the the power
nor the data for the solution of General
problems and consequently all of our
moral deductions are
arbitrary they only witness to our
prejudices if we're naturally timid or
to propensities and taste of for
self-confidence and I and I commented on
you know prejudices and propensities in
a previous video so I'm not going to
talk about that the reason I'm bringing
this up in this this particular uh video
is because what we're going to look at
in in great detail here well in some
detail uh I shouldn't promise
great is how shesto thinks about the the
creative act of thought itself and
thought has to be grounded in life and
any one single human beings life this by
the way is a problem that Hegel was was
very familiar with and attempted to try
to resolve himself in his
phenomenology any one single human life
has its sort of
penumbra of experience and you can move
you know from place to place and gather
more experience of course you're
forgetting a lot of things along the way
and you never develop maturity until
much later on so you may not be judging
the experience that you're having
correctly and so when you're working
with your first principles your your
starting points for philosophy you you
you know there's a tendency to think
that these are are not arbitrary that
that they impress themselves upon a
person and and they do impress
themselves upon a person but which ones
we actually pay attention to is in large
part arbitrary and arbitrary in several
different ways there's you know the
happen stances of where we wind up being
and the people that we're brought into
conflict with and what books we read and
and who we see talked about and what
sort of approaches uh people come to uh
not just in philosophy but literature
history all these Realms of thought that
we call the
humanities um do we have crappy teachers
do we have good teachers are the good
teachers actually in agreement with each
other or do they show us that there's
there's the possibility of of disharmony
among them these are all things that are
contingent and then you add to it the
dimension of
choice we're not
compelled in any sort of necessitating
way like a mechanism would be by it its
composition or by the way a computer
would be a different very much more
complicated electronic mechanism would
be by by its Hardware or its
programming we have the dimension of of
choice because we have we have wills and
they're so radically free that they
can't even determine themselves for all
time um we have to constantly make new
choices es and we become creatures of
the habits and we become creatures of
the previous choices that we've made
being brought forth into the
present so now if all that's
true these are very pressing questions
and these are questions that were raised
not only you know at the beginning of
modernity but also by philosophers in
the ancient and and medieval periods as
well what can we know for certain we
have a drive a wish a will
to have something we can depend upon and
there might be all sorts of
psychological explanations for this you
know fear of
Abandonment um you know who who knows
what what is actually going on behind
all of that but we do want certainty in
some things what can we know for certain
can we know anything for certain what
can we be completely assured of in a
sort of sense
of not only being able to provide
certainty like checking things off on a
list what can we feel morally assured
that will be the case what can we place
our trust
in um what would give us certainty we
have we have proposed for us all sorts
of things Logic for example maybe if we
just follow um the rules of
logic and we only agree to things that
we can derive from previous theorems or
axioms or however you like to put it in
your your particular framework of logic
even if you expand your logic wide
enough like say Hegel tried to
or Dewey or londal or compt or any of
these other people so it would cover a
much wider realm than formal
logic um there's always this quest to to
have something guaranteed something for
for certain in that what about
morality very often honored in the
breach but you know one of the things
that took place in the modern period was
this attempt to derive a scientific
morality it's still going on today we
have these neuroscientists you know
telling us that they finally crack the
code and they know what makes us tick
and you know usually the solutions that
they propose are not ones that shesto
would have been unfamiliar with because
the solutions they propose are actually
older than the turn of the
century um Society what what does
society need we talked about
utilitarianism in the broad sense you
know whatever works out for the greatest
number ends up getting a lot of weight
chestu actually says this is a very
interesting uh little quip that I also
considered starting with
um was section 37 very short section the
most important and significant
Revelations come into the world naked
without a word wordy garment to find
words for them is a delicate difficult
business a whole art that's part of what
what philosophy or literature or however
you want to put the realm of thought
that chest off is engaging in as a a way
of life whatever you want to call that
that's what its job
is stupidities and banalities on the
contrary appear at once in readymade
apparel gudy even as shabby so they're
ready straight away to be presented to
the
public Society the public the
masses even the masses that we call
Elites which are often just different
types of
masses they don't provide us with
anything really substantive anything
that we could sink our teeth into
anything that we can truly be satisfied
with what about
God there's an interesting one for
chesto um if you read other works of
shesto because he doesn't talk about God
that much in this one you find out God
is pretty mysterious and that God
actually often times for Shoff Shoff is
willing to totally bite the ex
existentialist bullet uh goes beyond
logic or morality or science or Society
or certainty or pick you know any sort
of form of necessity that you
like um we live in a period and shesto
was well aware of this where on the one
hand you know like n said God is dead
meaning that that people the the old
notion of God um has has ceased to have
the Allure that it had for many people
in solving problems the god of the gaps
you know it's really funny to see
atheists often times criticizing theists
as if um they weren't living in a post
nichan period you know as if theists
just believe in this God of the gaps or
stuff like that I mean people were were
starting to say that I don't really I
don't really buy that sort of thing if
if there is a God it's not going to look
an awful lot like that um which by the
way is a point Augustine made back you
know in the beginning of the Middle Ages
on the other hand people had
displaced
God and what God provided and again n
was criticizing this too and doski was
criticizing this into
science into the view that through some
sort of humanly
constructed completely or more and more
positively accurate depiction of the way
things
are we could attain certainty we could
be assured of things we could proceed in
a way in which we would no longer go
wrong as we had been all that time we
would be blessed so to speak
um that was the the dream of positivism
of of all different sorts whether it be
that of the
encyclopedists of comt later on logical
positivism of the unspoken positivism of
of so many other movements contemporary
today so um Shuff has a lot to say about
these things and I want to do something
very dramatic at the very beginning
and say that this was a mistaken
philosophy according to shestov now does
that mean that everything becomes
arbitrary in the sense that well we just
don't know anything we can't be sure of
anything no because to be a skeptic is
also in a certain way to to be within
this
problematic we have to work from our
experience but our experience is much
richer and has much more many more
Dimensions than we give it credit for in
part because it connects up with other
people including other
Geniuses people who have left Behind
These great literary monuments that
we're not just supposed to look at and
read and sort of imitate and
worship but which are supposed to make
us think which are supposed to provoke
in us a kind of
shock and a
recognition of what is actually out
there that we were lacking until we read
them and great literature does that for
you whether it's Plato or Homer or Dante
or you know the great literature of the
20th century I I personally I found
borase to be quite stimulating when I
was younger myself um
so let me shift
now
and go
to one of the problems that arises once
we actually dispense with this so if we
want to get rid of these questions like
what can we know for a certain what can
we be assured of
what would give us certainty of that
sort we can transpose the question
slightly and ask
instead
who who helps us understand make sense
out of reality and then we should ask
ourselves the question not just
who
but
why why do we think that they can they
can provide us with that and so he talks
about general rules this is a section 40
of the second part he says people go to
philosophers for general principles I
know this is true because I've been
doing Philosophy for about half my life
and people are always doing
this and since philosophers are human
they're kept supplying the market with
general principles but what sense is
there in them not at
all nature demands individual creative
activity from us men won't understand
this so they wait forever for the
ultimate truths from philosophy which
they will never get or science or
theology or you know pick some other
discipline that you like at the
time they wait forever for the ultimate
truths which they will never get why
should not every grownup person be a
Creator live in his own way at his own
risk and have his own
experience so it's saying
um we need to put ourselves there now
that doesn't mean that we we have to be
totally on our own and sort of recreate
de card again go into our Ste our stove
heated room and pretend like nobody else
in the world exists and then try to
recreate them
that would actually just be replication
wouldn't it that's already been
done he says children in raw youths must
go in go go in leading strings but adult
people who want to feel the Reigns
should be despised they're cowards and
slothful afraid to try the eternally go
to the wise to for advice and the wise
do not hesitate to take the
responsibility for the lives of others
they invent general rules as if they had
access to sources of knowledge what
Foolery the wiser no wise than the
stupid they only have more conceit and E
ephenry every intelligent man laughs in
his soul at bookish
views and our books not the work of the
wise they're often extremely interesting
but only in so far as they do not
contain general rules when they deviate
from this putting out a blueprint and
that's probably actually what makes so
many management books so so incredibly
boring and so many self-help books so
incred ibly boring now that I think
about it the fact that they're just like
general rules you know you get sucked in
because they have a couple you know
anecdotes about Carol and Jim and so and
so who had this problem and you know by
the way they're only writing those those
not because they believe in them but
because you know you got to put
something in there to catch people's
attention and drive the point home and
then they come out with these truisms
and you're like oh God I've seen this
before and for every little nugget you
have to that that's valuable in these
kind of works you have to dig and dig
and dig that's part of why I like WR
literature because there's a hell of a
lot more nuggets in them uh right on the
surface and you don't have to do quite
so much
digging I suspect that's why shest like
that
too so shestov concludes this passage by
saying there are no all binding
Universal judgments let us manage with
non-binding non-universal ones only
professors will suffer for it so we
still actually need to
make
judgments we're not dispensing with the
act of having to decide of having to say
this is right this is wrong I think that
this is the way to go this is preferable
this is less preferable we have to do
all of
that we have to also become okay shest
off would say with with not trying to
make our views on these things into
absolutely binding judgments on
everybody so it would be exactly the
opposite of somebody like Kant but
equally opposite the views of somebody
like a utilitarian like Miller Bentham
where it's an appeal to sort of
universality of rational beings whether
it be just you know pure reason or sort
of well hos would fit over here too sort
of putting all the voices together and
then seeing what what what composite
comes of it um
we have to actually decide for
ourselves whose voices we're going to
worry about as
criteria should I subject my choices My
Views to K's categorical imperative and
deant his way of thinking about
things that's a
choice should I do it with Socrates I
think I'd do better with Socrates and
Plato than I would with Kant but Kant
would still be better than you know some
other people um there's at least still
some questions open that God couldn't
close the point is though we have to
make non-binding judgments that are
nonetheless judgments and they have to
do with our engagement with reality and
reality isn't just something that we get
to know and get to act on reality also
acts upon us as
well
through
experience so all of this has been a
long sort of circumlocution to get to
the point where I really wanted to go
and that is to talk about how shest off
sees creative
activity then derivative activity and
then the figure of what we're going to
call the profit so let's talk about
creative activity itself and shest off a
very creative person
I I think he's dead on in what he has to
say
um he says there's a section called
practical advice section 42 of of part
one people who read much must always
keep it in mind that life is one thing
literature another so you know we have
to avoid falling into the book so to
speak not that authors invariably lie I
declare there are writers who rarely and
most reluctantly lie but one must know
how to read and that isn't easy out of a
100 book readers 99 have no idea what
they're reading about it's a common
belief for example any writer who sings
As suffering must be ready at all times
to open his arms to the weary and heavy
laden this is what readers feel when
they read his books then when they
approach him with their woses and find
out that he runs away without looking
back at them they're filled with
indignation and talk of the discrepancy
between word and
deed where is the fact is the sing has
more than enough woes of his own and he
sings them because he cannot get rid of
them you know uh it'd be sort of if if
you went to a writer of pornography and
they turned out not to be a sexy person
or you go to um a writer
of detective literature and there's
nothing mysterious whatsoever about them
um writers write about the things that
they're focused on and I know this is
the case for me with the kind of writing
that I do yet academic writing we write
about the things that puzzle us that we
can't get out of our system that's why
for example I I've got writings on
Thomas Hobbs and I am not a Hoban by any
means but um there's things about his
work that draw me in that make me want
to think and write about that
and what happens people don't understand
how it works um
for the kind of creativity that's that's
required um for for writing um later on
actually earlier on he says the raptures
of creative activity empty words
invented by men who never had an
opportunity of judging from their own
experience but who derive their
conclusions syllogistically this this
actually deserves to be put on the board
because it's such a a funny thing to say
so what is a syllogism a ol
ism is a form of argument not the only
form and as a side note what Aristotle
called syllogism need not be understood
as as what the Scholastics and later
logicians called it it was a little bit
wider but he says if a creation gives us
such Delight
so
this is actually not a syllogism by the
way it's actually an enemy if a
syllogism gives us such
Delight what
must the
Creator
experience and you notice this is not
put in syllogistic form but we can
easily do so
by deleting
this saying the
Creator turn this not into a question
but into a declaration the Creator must
experience uh something quite
similar in delight and what's missing in
between here there's some sort of bridge
this is what Aristotle actually calls an
enamine in an enem the audience has to
supply the missing
premise or the conclusion or you know
other bits and what's what's missing
here well there's an assumption that's
being made and it is an if then
that if a creation gives such Delight to
us to who to The
Observer
the Creator must
experience
similar uh
delight and what's missing here is an if
then if creation if observing creation
gives Delight then creating creative
things must give Delight as well and how
do you know that's
true what would that actually be based
upon who could actually make that sort
of assertion even as a non-binding
judgment not a necessary judgment
applying to all but just a nonbinding
judgment It could only be creators It
could only be people who actually have
some experience of the processes not
just the products but the processes of
creation and what does shestov tell us
about this he
says usually the Creator feels only
vexations every creation is created out
of the Void
here actually he's saying something very
similar to haiger about the nothing uh
in in you know what is metaphysics at
the best the maker finds himself
confronted with a formless meaningless
usually obstinate and stiff matter which
yields reluctantly to form and he does
not know how to begin each time a new
thought is engendered so often must that
new thought which for the moment seems
so brilliant and fascinating be thrown
aside as worthless and this is indeed
part of the process of creation as
creators throughout the ages have told
us it is not a you know just throw stuff
up there on the canvas and hey it looks
good you have to ruin a lot of canvases
and spill a lot of paint before you come
up with a beautiful picture you have to
make a lot of terrible music before you
start making mediocre music before you
start making decent music before you
start making good music before you start
making brilliant music when it comes to
writing you have to throw out most of
what you write even again when it comes
to academic writing the best advice that
I was ever given about writing my
dissertation was that I needed to write
three pages every weekday and then at
the end of the the week on that Saturday
go back over those 15 pages and call out
three or four pages that were not
complete
crap and get rid of the rest or keep it
for whatever I wanted to do if I wanted
to play around with it later um that
would be fine but I needed to find some
stuff that was actually decent in all of
that that Meandering
around that is what's required um
creative work is is tough and I'd like
to say two other things that he's not
mentioning here one is is that the
Creator not only works upon what it is
that they're
creating often times the creator has to
work upon
themselves and that is even tougher
because you've got really no idea what
you're what you're creating when you
start changing yourself when you start
monkeying around with your drives and
desires and how you're going to
interpret your
experiences any of those sorts of things
it's really going out on a limb and this
holds just as much for the philosopher
as for the performance artist you know
if we want to think about like risky art
usually we think about stuff over there
but philosophy is like that too and so
is generating a new reading of
Hamlet and so is putting Hamlet on a
stage there's all these these risks that
have to be taken all this playing around
with things that don't seem to pay off
that's what creative activity consists
in the other thing that I want to say
too
is anybody who is trying to rework their
life whether it be their person their
their their uh outward circumstances
um if they don't have a blueprint for
doing that and often times where the
most important things aren't very good
blueprints they're engaged in this
process and it's a painful process it's
not a Funtime just you know finger
painting doing whatever you like so he
says um creative activity is a continual
progression from failure to failure and
the condition of the Creator is usually
one of uncertainty mistrust and
shattered nerves the more serious and
original the task for which a man sets
himself the more tormenting is the self-
misgiving for this reason even Men of
Genius cannot keep up the creative
activity to the last as soon as they
here's where now that the twist takes
place as soon as they've acquired their
technique they begin to repeat
themselves a cycle begins well aware
that the public willingly endures the
monotony of a favorite even finds virtue
in it every connoisseur of art is
satisfies if he recognizes in a new work
the accepted man of the artist and here
we're getting to something really
interesting so
um let me put it to you in very
blunt but hopefully still choian
terms so we have the
artist or The
Thinker and
they are living a life right and through
that they have experience and their
experience is giving them some sort of
hard-earned
principles and ideas and those go into
a
product now that product could be a work
of
art
it could be a style of
life it could be a
philosophy there's all sorts of things
could be a self-help book could be a
self-help movement could be a new diet
um could be a new management style
there's there's all sorts of things we
don't necessarily have to restrict it
just to artists and and people in the
humanities I mean this could actually
apply to people in business management
um that's probably actually a a sign
that it's that there's some truth to it
so the artist has to
struggle through this
process right and they have to struggle
because in order to get that product
they have to take raw materials and they
somehow have to put form into this
matter that that resists it and it might
be the matter is is
partly the artist
themselves they have to develop
technique to become a philosopher you
can't just read philosophy you actually
have to start thinking like a
philosopher you have to do
philosophy now once you've done this
there's a Temptation and that's what
he's talking about here there's actually
a double
Temptation and this comes about because
there is
a
public and the public
just sees this and appreciates that says
I like that make me some
more and that's a hell of a lot easier
to do the second time around isn't it
the artist is able they now know or the
philosopher or the the manufacturer they
now know how to do the
process um we could think about this in
terms of moral reformation and going
from vices and accia to developing a
virtue are all the virtues the same do
we develop them all in the same way well
maybe you figure out how to be
courageous to make of yourself a
courageous person as the product now you
just got to do the same thing with
Justice or good humor or uh righteous
anger or charity or something like that
but maybe they're not the same and maybe
by superimposing the same form you're
just repeating the same thing and you're
not really generating any new radically
new products and maybe you're starting
to slip away from reality and the public
is going to applaud you for that because
they can recognize it they can say yeah
yeah I I get this uh I didn't get it the
first time around but I wasn't an early
adopter as we say but but now now that
it's on Facebook and uh you know
whatever website um pick whatever blog
you like um I mean just think about the
fact that blogs have become a big thing
now when originally they were just
people just putting random stuff up
there or you know having to work really
hard to make some some sense out of
things once the public has a form they
can identify with it's very easy for the
artist or thinker to slip into that the
other thing
is and this is where
um chest off is saying something very
profound about philosophy
itself it's not just a danger for the
public it's it's not just a danger for
that
thinker it's a danger for the ones who
will come after it's a danger for what
we might
call I'm I'll put them over
here
the
disciple the
disciple or the
student so why is there a great danger
for the disciple or the student coming
out of this entire process of creative
activity and then
appropriation
reduplication and calling for more
creative
activity why is that an issue well
here's what shest says theories of
sequence and consequence are binding
only on the disciples not on the
Masters fathers of great ideas is tend
to be very careless about their progyny
giving very little heed to their future
career so let's let's take Philosophy
for example and we can then then extend
this into artwork or music or other
things so somebody like Plato comes
around and Plato is is a a student of
Socrates and he's inheriting a lot of
thought from Socrates but he's also
going he's he's surpassing his his his
teacher um if if you know zenfon
Socrates is um in some respects the
Baseline for for and what it has in
common with Plato Socrates if that's the
real Socrates then Plato went very far
beyond his his master and brought
together a lot of other
influences is Plato completely
consistent
no he's not even consistent in in the
stories that he has Socrates tell about
you know what happens after we die there
are points of consistency that run
through
things
but there's some inconsistencies as
well and what happens then when the
disciples come around they tread the
same footsteps they say we've got to be
able to find some way to to to
systematize this to make sense out of
this and you know in a certain respect
the the real Pless the real Hees to
Plato and his passion and his power are
people like on on one hand platinus and
on the other hand way down the line
kard not so much the people of his his
school um so there's a danger for the
Disciples of forgetting something that
the Masters
knew he says conscientious disciples
wasting away under the arduous effort to
discover that which does not exist are
brought to despair of their task what is
the what is the task the off The
Offspring of one and the same
philosopher frequently bear
such small resemblance to one another
it's impossible to discern the family
connection
um then these people having uh ceased
their attempt at reconciling glaring
contradictions they only insist the
harder on the necessity for studying the
philosophers studying them minutely
circumstantially historically
philologically even so the history of
philosophy is
born um and what he's talking about is
history of philosophy there is something
very different than what I conceive of
history of philosophy as being and what
I try to do for instance in these videos
what he means is this sort of scientific
you know determining why exactly did
liit think that thought there what was
going on in history that led him to use
that
term and that's very boring stuff
ultimately it it can be quite useful it
can be handy it can be interesting for a
little while but once you've produced it
you're you're less saying so what now
reading live
and thinking the thoughts of livets
that's a whole different ball game and
every great
philosopher we think of them as like you
know discovering great truths that are
out there and you know bringing them
down to earth and saying hey look at
this you know there's a system here
really what they're doing is they're
kind of like sticking themselves into
reality and wedging part of it open and
saying aha there's something there and
that act of like doing the JW of Life
almost so to speak um is is a way in
which they do something creative
something productive something that
their disciples their students are not
um are not doing that's why you know
who's the greatest platonist ever
Aristotle because he he did it
differently than than Plato he he said
aha I can do that
too but I'm not going to do it like you
did I'm going to do some things a bit
differently um
he talks about this a little bit a
little bit more um saying in the
ultimate questions of life we're not a
bit nearer the truth and our ancestors
were theories of sequence and
consequence are binding only upon
disciples whose single virtue lies in
their scrupulous logical developing of
their Master's idea but their masters
chesta says invent ideas and therefore
have the right to substitute one for the
other The Sovereign power which Pro
which proclaims a law has the same power
to abolish it but the duty of the
subordinate consists in the praise and
the consequential interpretation and the
strict observance of the dictates of the
higher
will so what's what's going on with all
this well again we can think of this
this process of trying to
attain certainty something that that can
be assured something that we know has
value it worked out the first time for
pick whoever you like say Hegel so
therefore if we just stick with you know
hegel's logic and phenomenon ology and
try to interpret the whole world through
it we'll get something kind of similar
to
that or maybe we should like
Marx turn the dialectic upside
down or maybe we should like kard say
dialectic is all great but you left out
this strata up here the
religious or we should like Maurice
Blondell say I love this dialectic idea
of yours but um there's so much more
that you didn't actually get into it
that I'm going to take a new look and
I'm going to do it through not through
thought not through being but through
action those are the people who aren't
disciples those are the people who are
themselves new artists and thinkers so
here's the here's the
alternative that one has to
decide when you love some some
philosophy when you love some work of
art when you love some movement when you
when there's something that you you
really like and you're not just um being
the admiring public but you actually
want to create yourself uh and this
could go for you know moral life as well
um when when there's a a way of of
living a way of praying a way of
relating to others that you particularly
admire are you going to look at the
person who derived that as having had
the final word on it
and that this product you know reflects
some sort of
necessity that constrains any
possible new thing on your part in which
case you're going to be a disciple and
you might be a very good disciple you
may in fact be very faithful to the to
the master and you might be the best
interpreter of their their stuff and
that's not that's not a bad
thing but it's not it's not creativity
for creativity it has to be done a new
and this doesn't mean you know burning
the ships and and uh departing
completely from all previous Norms you
know trying to do something so radically
different that you know the whole world
will sit up and praise you that's
already been done
actually what it means is to be able to
recognize to develop a capacity for
judgment for when you actually need to
to like you know lever it open and say I
need something that Plato didn't give me
and I've got this because I've got this
experience that's given me some new
ideas that I can work with and maybe I
can still use a lot of Plato's ideas or
Aristo or Hegel or chests for that
matter shesto would not want disciples
shesto is trying to provoke
everybody to in some way be an artist or
a
thinker
um there's one other thing that he says
about this sort of
process um he says each philosopher
invents his own truths which means he
asks his pupils to deceive himself in
the way that he shows but he reserves
for himself the option of deceiving
himself in his own way why why not allow
everyone to deceive himself just as he
likes that's that's kind of a nice
tongue and cheek
thing there is another danger that comes
with this whole thing as well
and that's not only the the the the
problem of you know having a public and
and disciples and all of that that would
be problematic enough because you know
who is
actually um attuned well enough attuned
to their own
BS and strong enough in their humility
to resist the Temptations to start going
along with that not a lot of us
including myself um there's a great
danger of The
Thinker turning into something different
so the Thinker is engaged in
creativity and
risk and they do so for a public they do
so for for you know people who are going
to come after them they're primarily
doing so for for
themselves there is a great danger when
they're successful of turning into
a
prophet what does it mean to be a
prophet well it means to speak for
God or something that is put on the same
level as God and you know if you look at
the the biblical prophets usually
they're not happy with being prophets at
all as a matter of fact usually they
they um they're fairly reluctant um some
of them actually have to be compelled
like like Jonah for example uh and even
after he's
compelled uh he he doesn't understand
why God did what he did and he's ticked
off with God and and God has to have a
little talk with him um Moses was a
reluctant Prophet
um Jeremiah definitely not not into the
prophet thing you know spends a lot of
time saying how crappy it is being a
prophet but there at the same time
there's a lot of people who who like the
the feeling of getting to sort of say
the things that matter to to be the the
the uh ones who are in touch with the
Zeitgeist the spirit of the age who
enunciated and you can see this there
there are some people at some times who
actually do without realizing it say the
things that need to be said at that
point in time and everything comes
together and you say yeah that makes
perfect
sense
now is that because of them or is that
because of the audience or is that
because of the times or is that because
of the
exigencies um it's usually a combination
of those but there's a tendency for
people then to assume the role of being
a
prophet of getting to speak for what
really matters you know whether they're
a prophit of being or God or science
what have you so there's a tendency for
this to happen with
um with writers in particular he says I
mean it's harder to be a profit with
music unless you actually have
lyrics um and people kind of expect
musicians to be full of crap anyway um
at least by the time they they're in
their 20s uh they they expect that he
says a writer particularly a young young
inexperienced inexperienced writer feels
himself under an obligation to give the
reader the fullest answers to all
possible questions conscience will not
let him shut his eyes to tormenting
problems so he begins to speak of first
and ultimate things as he can't say
anything profitable on such subjects
because he he doesn't know anything
right it's not the business of the young
to be profoundly philosophical he grows
excited he shouts himself to heness in
the end he's silent from exhaustion and
then if his words have had any success
with the public he's astonished to find
that he has become a
prophet whereupon If he if he'd be an
average sort of person he's filled with
an insatiable desire to preserve his
influence to the end of days that's the
danger with becoming a prophet is
wanting to
um remain
relevant wanting to be
in the
no wanting to be
right somebody gets a few things right
and now suddenly everybody's looking to
them it's a very dangerous situation
because it's hard to resist the
temptation to think I do know more than
these other
people as a matter of fact I've given so
much to my art to my discipline to my
skill I probably know way more and I
could like fix their lives and I could
make sense out of things the trouble is
prophets are often
wrong the only prophets that you can
rely on are those who actually speak
for God or the Divine or whatever it is
and telling them apart is kind of a
problem by the way if you look at the
Bible there's this constant problem
discussed of false
prophets so um he
says if he be more sensitive or gifted
than usual he begins to despise the
crowd and himself for having posed in
the stupid and disgraceful character of
a clown of lofty ideas so if you resist
the the temptation to become a Propet
you might become very
jaded some people can become both
dostoevski was an example of that
um that
uh shustoff talks about quite a
bit
um I'm talk about one other passage
where he talks about prophecy and then
I'm going to mention a work in which
this plays an important
role so he talks about
this um he
says when a man is Young he writes
because it seems to him he's discovered
a new Almighty truth which he must make
haste to impart to forlorn
mankind that's good that's that's you
know the Vitality of Youth later
becoming more modest he begins to doubt
his truths and then he writes to
convince
himself that's taking a bit more few
more years go by and he knows he was
mistaken all around so there's no need
to convince himself nevertheless he
continues to write because he's not fit
for any other work and to be accounted a
Superfluous man is so horrible people
don't want to think of themselves as
being out of the no as no longer having
anything relevant to say
um so so that is that is a key problem
um let me see
here now dovi is somebody who shest off
was very influenced by um takes very
seriously sees connections between dovi
and n and also highlights you know
parallels contrast between dovi and
other Russian authors like Tolstoy um
check off um
tanev tanv I think it's supposed to be
pronounced and
um he had an opportunity to write a
piece for um the 25
year anniversary of doki's
death what he wrote was called the gift
of
Prophecy and he starts off by talking
about how Vladimir um solovev used to
call doeski the prophet and even the the
prophet of God
and he says immediately after Sol solv
although often in complete independence
of him very many people looked upon
doeski as the man to whom the books of
human destiny were opened and this
happened not only after his death but
while he was still alive apparently dooi
himself if he did not regard himself as
a prophet at least thought it right that
all people should see a prophet in
him
and shestov is actually criticizing
dostoevski for for going along with this
and I I'm not actually going to read too
much from this because you know that's
not all things are possible this is a
different essay but I think I think it
is relevant here
um he
says how shall a man be greater than
himself in the world of
literature if he would move then by his
own will or in spite of it he must step
onto another plane
and this is plainly the beginning of
Prophecy in a writer in the general view
the prophet is always greater than the
writer and even the possession of Genius
is not always a guarantee against the
general
view um so how did how did Doki start
playing the
prophet um he talks about this he says
doeski wanted to be a prophet he wanted
people to listen to him and cry hosana
because I say again he thought if men
had ever cried hosana to anyone there
was no reason why he does sayi should be
denied the honor I mean you know if you
if you really have a lot to
say it's tempting to to be the prophet
because otherwise some other Schmucks
are going to come along and play the
prophet and and mislead people so you
might as well be the prophet just so
that people are misled a little less you
could
say he says um this is where I'm going
to actually end this he's making this
contrast he says the
underworld wherein his faded but lately
driven him it might seem forever now
appear to him a fantes magoria which had
never been real in the gal in the
Underworld had been born within him a
great hunger for God which lived long
there he fought a great fight the fight
of Life against death there for the
first time were made the new and awful
experiments with allied doeski with
everything that is rebellious and
Restless on Earth that's the beginning
that's the early
dooi what dooi wrote during the closing
years of his
life has value only in so far as dooes
past is reflected
therein he made no new Step outward as
he was so he remained on the eve of a
great truth but in the old days that did
not suffice him he hungered for
something Beyond but now he does not
want to struggle he cannot explain to
himself or to others what is really
happening within him he pretends to be
struggling still more he behaves as
though he had won the final Victory and
demands that his Triumph should be
acknowledged by public opinion he loves
to think the night is already passed and
the actual day begun and the GS and the
underworld reminding him that the day
are not yet are no more all the
evidences of a complete illusion of
Victory seem to be there let him only
choose the text and
preach and there's a lot more really
brilliant stuff in that essay but I I
don't want to again I don't want to take
away from all things are
possible so what we see is there there's
a problematic for anybody who is going
to do creative work whether that be as a
thinker as a lover as an artist as
somebody who's taking care of of other
people in their needs um these are all
ways in which we bring new things into
to existence and things that can be
quite
valuable things that reveal to us
something of the truth of who we are and
what the world is and of Good and Evil
and all these these things that we we
hunger for
answers uh
about but there are dangers we we can
very easily lose sight of just what
creative activity demands of us the fact
that there's a public ready to hear that
ready to flatter us ready to tell us we
should conform to its
tastes might make us
disciples might make us just parts of
that public might make us abandon the
need to do what we have to do in order
to to make creative work happen through
US often times in spite of us and the
greatest danger of all is of
succeeding and being
cast in the role of the Prophet because
once you're up on that dis it's very
difficult to want to get yourself
down but these demands these drives
these
concerns are
not
compatible not very compatible not even
remotely compatible with wanting to live
the genuinely philosophical life that
chof is sketching out in this great work
all things are possible